wir sind jetzt den dritten sommer
nacheinander und drei sommer die so
trocken sind wie sie jetzt wie es jetzt
gerade erleben
das gab es historisch fast noch gar
nicht
[Musik]
es ist ernst deutschland trocknet aus
die auswirkungen des klimawandels werden
immer sichtbarer
das beeindruckende ist eben dass es
nicht nur ein trockener ist wie das 2003
oder 2015 war sondern dass das jetzt mit
nachfolgenden trockenjahren zu tun haben
oder die die wasser defizite nicht mehr
kompensiert werden durch
niederschlagsreiche winter zum beispiel
sondern wo wirklich die defizite sich
anhäufen und diese serie an dorian die
setzt natürlich der vegetation zu und
setzt den wäldern sitzt den landwirten
zu
es ist die schlimmste dürre seit mehr
als 250 jahren das haben klimaforscher
der helmholtz gesellschaft in leipzig
berechnet
die wissenschaft ist alarmiert dass man
den wissenschaftlichen untersuchungen
ließ die sich verstärkt eben diesem
phänomen in mitteleuropa an dem dürren
austrocknung und damit verbunden auch
schädlingsbefall muss man sagen geht
bergab und zwar eigentlich muss man auch
was sagen brutal bergab die neuesten
zahlen der bundesregierung
unterstreichen dass in deutschland sind
in den vergangenen zweieinhalb jahren
rund 285.000 hektar wald verloren
gegangen eine fläche so groß wie das
saarland
um den wald sorgt sich auch christoph
von eisenhart rothe von der
schutzgemeinschaft deutscher wald
er hat uns die schäden im taunus gezeigt
man sieht hier überall noch die
abgesägten stümpfe das sind bäume die in
diesem sommer in diesem frühjahr sommer
2020 abgestorben sind und wir haben ein
ganz groß flächiges absterben der fichte
viele fonds leute sprechen davon dass
die fichte in den niederungen
wahrscheinlich den nächsten zwei drei
jahre vollständig verschwunden sein wird
die dürre macht die bäume auch anfällig
für schädlinge wie den borkenkäfer
geschwächte bäume können sich gegen die
eindringlinge schlechter wären
der käfer bot sich dann in die rinde
hier sieht man ein schönes beispiel das
ist also ein stück fichten rinde wie sie
ursprünglich am baum war
und da sind also ganz sicher auch zu
sehen und wenn man dann die innenseite
sieht dann sieht man sich der käfer 1
gebohrt die elterntiere haben hier die
sind in diesem gang eingelegt und haben
links und rechts davon ihre eier
abgelegt und von dort aus fressen sich
dann die larven in die entsprechenden
leitbahnen des baumes und wenn man sich
also vorstellt dass es der baum eine
senkrecht steht hier werden die
nährstoffe und das wasser noch umgezogen
und dann werden die kraft ja von dem
käfer entsprechend gekappt und der baum
vertrocknet sozusagen oben in seinem
witzel und stirbt ab
aber nicht nur die fichten sterben ab
auch die eigentlich bei uns heimische
woche leidet unter der trockenheit
dass es in den vergangenen wochen teils
heftig geregnet hat ist für die experten
kein grund zur entwarnung
man muss einfach dann am ende eine
bilanz man www war sie wie viel regen
fällt und wie viel verdunstet auch
wieder und dann fällt die bilanz leider
gottes negativ aus und dazu kommt dass
die böden eben sich auch verändern über
die zeit das wasser aufnahmevermögen der
blüten lässt durch eine zunehmende
trockenheit auch nach wir bräuchten an
sich drei monate durchgehend anträgen um
halbwegs den wasserspeicher wieder
aufzufüllen den wasserspeicher in bosen
meine ich damit
und dann ist sage ich mal noch keine
besonders große reserve da sondern das
ist erstmal dass der normalzustand ist
dann wieder hergestellt wissenschaftler
rechnen damit dass wir uns an wetter
extreme im sommer gewöhnen müssen
starkregen auf der einen dürre auf der
anderen seite jetzt muss einem schon ein
waldumbau kommen auf die verhältnisse
und auch die landwirtschaft muss sich
anpassen auf die verhältnisse wie was
jetzt haben das rückgängigmachen damit
damit rechnet dieser waldumbau hat
bereits begonnen es geht darum baumarten
mit unterschiedlichen eigenschaften zu
mischen und sorten zu pflanzen die
besser mit trockenheit zurechtkommen
im taunus wird mit verschiedenen sorten
experimentiert
die douglasie ist eine baumart die kommt
aus nordamerika sie wächst aber auch bei
uns sehr sehr gut
und der punkt ist aber der dass die
douglasie eigentlich von der ökologie
hier in die gegend gar nicht herein
passt und entsprechend ist diese
douglasien naturschutzfachlich der
durchaus sehr umstritten
horst fachlich aber durchaus sehr
interessant wie es weitergeht mit dem
deutschen wald hängt vor allem davon ab
wie entschlossen wir auf den klimawandel
reagieren damit wir uns solche
dürreperioden wie jetzt ersparen in
zukunft ist ganz klar die aussage der
wissenschaftler muss der die
erderwärmung abgebremst werden unser
radikal abgebremst werden wenn man es
nicht schaffen das heißt business as
usual dh die kohlendioxid steigt weiter
die temperaturen steigen weiter von
jetzt 1,5 grad plus dann auf zwei oder
drei grad plus in mitteleuropa das wäre
dann der schlimmste fall dann müssen wir
teilen mit einer vervielfachung der der
dürren und der wasserknappheit rechnen
[Musik]